from slay news Bill Gates warned civil
war is coming we'll bring it all to an
end but we've covered this before we
covered the story and actually got a ton
of play but Luke mentioned something
else that Bill Gates has a group of
people tracking what people say about
him on the internet and I didn't believe
it and so Luke was like pull it up
there's a quote from from Bill Gates
quote I have a group that tracks what's
on the web that's talking about things
that connect to me he said
overwhelmingly during the pandemic 95
percent was all the conspiracy theory
stuff that were right they were right
hold on a majority of it I would say 95
of that stuff nothing yeah majority of
it a lot of it there were some crazy uh
Looney Tunes that talked about aliens
and all this other stuff to to muddy the
waters here there was a lot of crazy
people that made stuff stuff up out of
nowhere but when it came to the
scientists the professionals the
researchers uh the politicians who came
forward that were censored they were
deemed conspiracy theories and a lot of
them were right and they weren't talking
about Bill Gates
a lot of the stuff people talk about
Bill Gates they go over the top with you
need to talk about Bill Gates in the
comments no no he says not about him he
says the pandemic he says overwhelming
during the pandemic it was all
conspiracy stuff right talking about
talking about him he says connect to me
he was saying that people were talking
about him and and during the pandemic it
was all conspiracy theory stuff
I'm saying be careful about the weird
lizard people attempts because that's
how they discredit you absolutely focus
on Bill Gates's Ted Talk where he says
we need to reduce population growth well
and then they start doing these things
claiming it's not about population
growth and I have to wonder what their
priorities are yeah but not only that if
you look at the statement above what the
quote that you just read there it says
specifically Gates also revealed that
he's been trying to come up with the
solution for tracking tackling
misinformation and conspiracy theories
so he's he's going after the individuals
who pretty much overall a lot of them
have been batting a hundred he's the one
he's the main guy funding News Guard
he's the one funding a lot of these
factors real quick we get a lot of flack
for this Microsoft has a as a contract
with News Guard not direct funding of
course he's but but he also came out and
it recently was revealed that he funded
Dan Crenshaw Mitt Romney Marco Rubio
he's also of course behind the inflation
reduction act he's bragging about how he
made that bill was a part of writing it
he's going to be enforcing it this is
the bill that of course provides 80 000
new IRS agents is going to be
centralizing a lot of control and
regulations here so I mean this man with
242
000 acres in 18 states talking about
keeping an eye on people who talk about
him I mean that that should that should
raise some eyebrows we also have this
story Bill Gates admits that telling
people not to eat meat won't solve
climate change despite previously saying
U.S should move to 100 synthetic beef
and investing in plant-based firms you
know look they do all these things they
say climate change but it kind of feels
like what they're really saying is
overpopulation
well yeah and and also this is
self-interested Bill Gates has a lot of
patents a lot of Investments and a lot
of money into meatless diets that of
course a lot of the science has been
questioned some of the science has
actually even been debunked and and
purely it does highlight something that
a lot of people do see as something
nefarious since of course meat
especially organ meat has a lot of
important macronutrients has a lot of
important uh nutrition that a lot of
people are being denied the access to so
a lot of people are of course are coming
up with theories but obviously with this
man having so much control so much land
so much money so much power there should
at least be some accountability at least
some criticism to him and his his
organization I think the factory farming
industry is grotesque and it's not
something that gets enough attention in
modern media like when you see the pools
of large lakes of blood and feces like
brown red thesy mud that they and
they'll ban like drones above their
factories so you can't see them and then
when you see in like internal videos of
like these no offense to people able to
work in these jobs because I don't know
what the hell that must be like to kill
animals all day but like like people
that have gone so far they see the pig
and they just think it's it's it's a
thing that I need to kill right now and
they'll take baby ones and smash them
pick them up by their leg and smash
their heads on the concrete you hear the
baby pigs squealing and dying and then
it's like this is how we have been
sourcing the meat for this amount of
population I get where Bill Gates is
coming from because this is grotesque
I think it's part of what about all the
animals and that's not what he's saying
but what about all the other animals
that are killed and hurt in the making
of a lot of these you know vegan oh yeah
when you talk about when they Harvest
Grain for instance they take these
combines and they grind up huge amounts
of wheat but all these deer are in there
they just hunker down and wait rabbits I
mean it's the not animal friendly the
way that they harvest absolutely Mass
amounts of grain absolutely not but but
again this is not kind of what Bill
Gates is yeah he's not talking about
that he's talking about it takes too
much carbon to make a cow and factory
farming is intensely carbon it's carbon
intensive the crazy thing I learned lot
of burps the crazy thing I learned is
that Broiler chickens Factory right like
you know people say like such thing as a
factory farm look at these pictures of
like this building full of just chickens
six weeks until they they harvest the
chicken that's crazy to me because we
have you know backyard chickens six
weeks is Tiny you know so it's got them
on steroids they I guess yeah they're
hopped up on goof balls to make them
grow real quick and nasty like yeah but
I don't know look just because we have
problems in that capacity I'll I'll
admit Bill Gates telling people not to
eat meat is is nuts my point here is
they keep saying climate change but look
at the actions that they're engaged in
when they're saying hey we want to get
rid of fossil fuels it's like okay well
people will die if you do that it's like
yeah well climate change it's like okay
well we don't want people farming in the
Netherlands right now during a food
shortage you know during a war it's like
okay well that's not climate change
they're like we're concerned about
nitrogen levels in the Netherlands it's
like yeah but there's a food shortage
coming because of the war in Ukraine
right like oh yeah well whatever they
should stop making food so you want the
food to be worse that there was a great
point that was brought up by Jeremy
boring when he's on the show and he said
nothing matters about humans we are
humans our experience is human we care
about The Human Experience so this idea
that we would sacrifice Humanity for
something else makes no sense okay he
said something to that effect I don't
want to misquote him but he made a
really good point
like humans exist for humans right like
we we we we have to be good stewards of
the earth that's what he said but also
like our drives our passions our desires
our experiences is relative to to humans
so if we were thinking of sacrificing
all of humanity for the sake of you know
climate change well what's the point
stopping climate change to save humans
when humans are going to die if you
don't have food something doesn't add up
there you know what I mean yeah I think
that there's you know the person saying
there's too many people in this world so
you got to give us all the power and all
the money because we are going to help
everyone uh should really have someone
looking a side-eyed at them and again
you have to look at Bill Gates and the
work that he's produced you know the the
products that he produced Vanda Vandana
Shiva actually came out and and did a
very excellent uh kind of speech about
what Bill Gates has done to India with
his centralization of farmers you see
what he has called for you see the work
that he has done with China advising
them working with them on many projects
calling for many of the most restrictive
coveted policies celebrating their
lockdowns I mean this this is a man who
has a vision for Humanity that I think
should be critiqued a little bit and not
promoted because the corporate media
regurgitates a lot of what he has to say
uncritically as of course he also gives
hundreds of millions of dollars to the
corporate media he's invested in the
guardian the BBC MSNBC and his money has
been spread around everywhere especially
in the scientific Community where it has
created the bill chill where many
scientists are even too afraid to
criticize him or his products because
they know some kind of funding is going
to be taken away if they criticize him
and this is why in my opinion Bill Gates
is bragging about how he has people that
track people online that talk about him
as he's now trying to delve into dealing
with misinformation and conspiracy
theories yeah it's not a coincidence
why can't these Super Rich ass people
just like be super rich and be happy
what is the emptiness in their soul what
is driving this now as a Christian I can
like I I have my own thoughts on this
however like why why make the world the
worst place well why take away meat for
the rest of us like what a miserable
existence take away your abilities
the guy works a nine to five in the coal
pits and all he wants is to put a
hamburger you got on the grill you got
it backwards where is the opposition
why is it that Bill Gates and all of
these other billionaires are dumping
money into wokeness CRT climate change
stuff and then on the inverse nothing I
mean literally not literally nothing but
dramatically less yeah you know I talk
about this quite a bit and I I was
saying once you know I wish people who
had money would do things with it and
they don't and some people point out
yeah but like the woke people do and
then I was like yeah that's a good point
maybe people shouldn't and then I
thought about you know Mackenzie Bezos
got what 28 billion dollars for
divorcing Jeff and then she puts two
billion dollars into woke stuff at least
it was reported from some Outlets she's
dumping all this money into all these
whoa causes and then I'm just like okay
where's the story about a major
libertarian conservative anti-wolf
person doing something similar I went to
Morgantown West Virginia it's like a
college town and it's rundown and
there's a lot of reasons why it is and
it seems like it's orchestrated big
investment firms drive up the price of
of building so that no one in the
community can buy them so that
businesses can't be open nobody can
afford rent and then it becomes this
just slum then they start giving out
free needles to everybody and now
everything is just crime poverty drugs
and then I'm like
one billionaire a billionaire could go
in there and buy like seven buildings
and then just be like make stuff to the
community to revitalize everything they
can counter it why don't they do stuff
like that why is it it's always people
like Bill Gates and George Soros now I
know long ago there were stories of the
Coke brothers or whatever I don't know
what they what they were doing or they
are doing I just know that as much as
there is some stuff that Peter Thiel
does for the most part we only ever hear
about these big woke leftist
billionaires who think there's too many
people when we get close Elon Musk gets
close to buying Twitter and doing
something he then says I'm gonna back I
was a bad idea I don't want to do it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there